- IN THE PIT OF MY
TAR-BLACK GUTS.
- LITTLE LOOK INTO THE BROKEN
MIND OF INUIT ANDY AGAIN.
FEEL LIKE MY CAT JUST DIED.
OKAY, TUNES, YOU READY
TO READ ALOUD?
- TUNES, DON'T FREAK.
YOU'RE FANTASTIC AT THE ARTS.
- THANKS, MIKEY.
[wheelchair hums]
THIS POEM IS ABOUT
OUR NATIONAL PARK, BANFF,
AND FIRE SAFETY.
[clears throat]
"BANFF IS ON FIRE.
CONDITIONS ARE DIRE.
"HEAVY, BLACK SMOKE,
TOO MUCH FOR FIRE FIGHTERS.
"YOU EVER HEARD OF ALBERTA?
"WELL, THE FIRE IS MUR-DAH
TO THE NATIONAL PARK,
"AND ITS FLORA AND FAUNA.
"I'M A BANFF MOTHER HOSER,
BORN AND RAISED.
"I'M A BANFF MOTHER HOSER.
STOP THE BLAZE.
FIRE PREVENTION!"
[applause]
- WHOA, WELL, ALL RIGHT.
WHO KNEW WE HAD A YOUNG DRAKE
ON OUR HANDS.
OKAY, THAT WAS GREAT,
WITH A POSITIVE MESSAGE
ABOUT OUR FORESTS.
- MACKEREL, TUNES.
THAT POEM WAS BLAZING HIP HOP.
YOU COULD BE A REAL RAPPER.
- THANKS, MIKEY.
WORD.
[school bell rings]
- [whistling]
- HEY, LEGS, LET'S CHAT.
- YEAH, WE NEED YOU
FOR OUR GRADE-13 PRANK.
- A PRANK? BUT IT'S NOT
MEAN-SPIRITED, IS IT?
- NOTHING TOO RADICAL.
- WE'RE GOING TO FILL UP
COACH TEACHER'S OFFICE
WITH PASTA.
[laughter]
- PARDON, I DON'T THINK
I FOLLOW.
- WE JUST NEED TO FILL UP
YOUR AUTO WITH PASTA,
THEN PUT IT
IN COACH TEACHER'S OFFICE.
- [laughs]
HMM, I HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT.
- DON'T BE SUCH A HEN,
EH, WHEELS?
- OKAY, FAIR ENOUGH.
[school bell rings]
- HEY, TUNES, I KNOW YOU'RE
A FIRST-RATE RAPPER NOW,
BUT WHERE ARE WE GOING?
- RIGHT THERE.
- IT SEEMS LIKE A BIT
OF A DANGEROUS NEIGHBORHOOD, NO?
- I'LL BE FINE.
I'M A REAL RAPPER NOW.
- YEAH, I JUST FEEL LIKE THERE'S
SOME ROTTEN PEARS MAYBE.
- IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SUCH A HEN ABOUT IT,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO COME IN.
- I'M NOT BEING HEN ABOUT IT.
I JUST CARE ABOUT YOUR SAFETY.
- DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
I'LL BE FINE.
- FINE, THEN.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST GET OUT?
- I NEED MY CHAIR, MIKEY.
- OH, SORRY.
I FORGOT ABOUT YOUR DISABILITY.
[door-ajar alert beeper beeping]
PLEASE DON'T ROB US.